um I kind of just started a couple days
ago um but um I've read and a lot of a
lot of notes over the years this my
first time actually reading this from
start to finish um you may remember this
this is this is a couple years ago uh
Lebron James being asked he's reading
the uh he's apparently reading the
autobiography of Malcolm X and he was
asked what his biggest takeaway from the
book
was uh tellor you want to follow up yeah
um so you are holding the autobiography
of Malcolm X along with Alex Haley I
don't know how far you are into the book
but what's your biggest takeaway so far
um I kind of just started a couple days
ago um but um I've read and a lot of a
lot of notes over the years this my
first time actually reading this from
start to finish um but just a very
um very smart man very very very smart
man and basically
um his words in the in the 60s and uh
and what was going on is actually what's
going on today
still him understanding the um how
powerful um The Negro can be he used
that word a lot how powerful we are um
but we have to unite and uh we have to
be together we have to stand strong
because there's always going to be
obstacles there's always going to be um
you know things that's going to be
thrown at us where they try to weaken us
um they try to f up make us feel like
we're not kings and queens um and it's
going to come from all you know
different races and different shapes and
sizes and things of that nature
um and um just a very powerful minded uh
gentleman and um and it's it's
unbelievable to to kind of read
something that's coming directly from
him about 10 different jokes that I
could tell you there and most of them
would end my career so I'll just leave
it at um that guy is the Cala Harris of
the NBA what the high hell did he say
there no nobody knows it's meaningless
driil meaningless utter driil and just
one more one more from the meaningless
and utter driil category here's LeBron
explaining what his uh favorite scene is
his favorite line favorite scene is from
The Godfather Trilogy it is a question
uh not related to the game but since it
has been a lot of publicity yesterday
and today about Godfather part two which
is the the scene or or the moment or the
phrase or the quote you like more from
the movie oh from The Godfather uh um
it's it's too many different phrases uh
and too many different lines in that
movie to just uh categorize one
um but whichit is the one which inspirat
you represent you more I mean each movie
is 9 hours long I mean what do you want
me to
do I mean there so many I don't know
I'll let you pick one and our roll with
it is it's a great the horse head in the
bed The Godfather dying at the end the
tomatoes his grandson there's like we
could do a lot here but why do they do
this with everything how about him just
say you know what I actually haven't
seen it or I don't remember they lie
about everything you know it's like that
remember that Obama clip we showed you a
couple months back where that guy on
Comedy Central is asking Obama what his
favorite his wrap-up music for the year
was and Obama lists out a whole bunch of
songs and then he's like can you tell me
one line from one of those songs and
Obama's like oh there's so many lines in
all those songs I can't tell you all
Lebron there's so many these movies are
so long I can't come up with what is
wrong with
people